vous connaissez michel rocard
personnellement non
vous connaissez la question michel
rocard
vous connaissez pas la question de
michel rocard est-ce que embrasser s'est
trompé non ah bon qu'est ce que c'est
que cette philosophie que vous avalez le
sais pas je demande mal joué mais ça
dépend du contexte et j'espère bien que
non ouais et sucer c'est tromper et par
devoir sucer c'est tromper non plus non
plus est-ce que embrasser s'est trompé
souvent trompe plus avec le coeur car
quelques sexe m'éclate est déjà non et
est-ce que sucer c'est tromper mais je
sais pas je demande écrite on me disait
que non est ce qu'on brasse et s'est
trompé non non on peut embrasser pour
moi c'est une autre fille sans tromper
brasse et comment sur la bouche c'est
que la langue nabawi alors bien sûr même
avec la langue s'est pas trompé pas
encore si toute façon parce que c'est
laid ouais c'est vrai si c'est trop tard
c'est dans la tête marine l'embrasser
s'est trompé bah oui vous aussi vous
dites servait donc sucer c'est tromper
aussi bon dernière question est-ce que
sucer c'est tromper
il l'a fait aussi celui-ci ou se faire
sucer se faire sucer en là je voulais
c'est là parce que là vous êtes à
prendre sympathisé genre pas est-ce que
se faire sucer c'est tromper clinton lui
par exemple il dit que non ça dépend par
qui a eu d'accord est-ce que vous pensez
que embrasser s'est trompé non non on
peut embrasser une femme ou un homme
sans tromper oui est-ce que sucer c'est
tromper je ne vais pas vous répondre
voilà la chaussée s'est trompé
là on arrive à la question importante
eux dit question michel rocard et je me
suis fait épingler par laure adler com a
connu beaucoup moins puritaine et une
certaine époque au sujet de cette
question alors à terre laure adler elle
a dit que thierry ardisson demandé cette
question là et que c'est la choqué on
l'a connu moins choqué laure adler bien
alors regardez moi bien les nastase est
ce que sucer c'est tromper je sais pas
je ne parle pas bien français
est ce que pour vous embrasser s'est
trompé ouais c'est grave si votre 9
embrasser un autre mec vous considère
qu'elle vous trompe avec le recul vrai
ça peut faire un man doc gynéco est-ce
que sucer c'est tromper si elle l'a bien
fait enfin comme comme je l'avais
manteau cerles est ce que pour vous
sucer c'est tromper
oui ah ouais
ah ouais
ah non mais c'est une question à sens
inverse non cela dépend avec qui
il faut se concentrer mon garçon est ce
que pour vous source et trompait s'était
cassé koala la réponse
c'est un certain jordan ouais j'ai
entendu joker terreur j'utilise mon
joker tombe quand on prend un joker ça
tombe sur la personne qui est à côté de
vous donc bah oui est ce que pour vous
sucer c'est tromper
oui bon voilà à dernière question celle
aplatir fabrice santoro est ce que sucer
c'est tromper
oui est-ce que se faire sucer c'est
tromper annonce
embrasser ce fonds mais ça dépend où
embrasser ou sur la bouche un smack ou
avec la langue grecque la langue ça
dépend pour la femme je crois que c'est
tromper mais pour moi non pour mardi
mais moi je vais dire que c'est tromper
bien avant de mettre la langue s'est
trompé c'est tromper que dans ta tête tu
as plus qu'une envie c'est de grimper
dessus même si tu y as pas toucher ça
s'est déjà trompé
bien sûr alors que alors que 20 matchs
et sans s'en être pris par la tête là
s'est pas trompé ah qu'est ce que tu
racontes pas si elle embrasse quelques
risques est ce qu'ils se jugera 30 et
moi je trouve pas ça grave d'embrasser
je trouve que l'on rencontre des gens
dans une soirée réclame avec la langue
qui dérape c'est pas et puis on va
s'aimer calanques c'est pas juste comme
se pencher tous les deux en avants sont
touchés c'est l'un contre l'autre c'est
tout un tas devant les dernières
questions
la pierre est ce que se faire sucer
c'est tromper
ah bah oui bah ouais bah oui bon là pour
le coup c'est bon c'est vrai que je
m'excuse mois là est-ce que danser s'est
trompé dans ce cas oui
amano s qu'embrasser s'est trompé
[Musique]
c'est pas génial quand même invité à
l'émission fois ci après non la question
michel rocard l'a vu question michel
rocard oui c'est tromper ça commence
vous trompez pas trompé quand il ya un
acte tantôt pop up un baiser s'est
trompé déjà oui je pense
même sans la langue mais sur ces trois
jacques et c'est normal non
mais si tu as femmes embrasse avec
jacquet vous connaissez la question
michel rocard oui oui évidemment
évidemment même si c'est une petite [ __ ]
est-ce que embrasser s'est trompé non
est ce que vous connaissez et michel
rocard jusque rennais lui s'est trompé
personne avec lui est-ce que sucer c'est
tromper
bah ça dépend ce qu'on suspend
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un
peu de bleu